[Music]
the uss
watson will arrive at the chongqing
court on the 16th
to collect and disarm the remaining
intercontinental ballistic missiles
this joint action will complete
denuclearization
dear viewers as i stand here speaking to
you we are experiencing an earthquake
my god
here
so
so
[Music]
uh
[Music]
there are four magma chambers located
under the pectin mountain the remaining
three chambers will then explode
consecutively how much time do we have
before it explodes again
breaking news the pec 2 mountain has
erupted according to the latest analysis
it looks like there are three more giant
magma chambers under the
sun
we're sending you out on the new mission
report to base immediately
it's our job to fly there dismantle a
few missiles and get back home safely
okay
consider him extremely dangerous and
whatever you do don't let your guard
down protective suit
i ate over there i sent a bunch of boy
scouts
maybe he's not even lee i had a little
surprise visitor himself
give me a gun what
went better than i expected it to
if we don't stop them it's over for the
north and for the south so untouch me
and let me out of here
do you really believe that we'll be able
to get there on time
but if we can hit it we can stop the
last eruption
[Music]
you